[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people
build wealth new work that they love and
create actual amazing relationships Dr
John deloney Ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
and a big day for Dr John and all the
folks here at Ramsey we are really
excited his brand new book building a
non-anxious life goes on sale today the
pre-order goes on sale today and many of
you have already responded to the
pre-sale and the book actually comes out
October 8th October 3rd October 3rd
thank you and uh it is absolutely
incredible I'm very excited as the CEO
of Ramsey and as a fellow Ramsay
personality for the content of this book
it's absolutely incredible how to build
a non-anxious life so John
how do you build I'm still figuring this
out myself
um so don't don't put out a book in
front of 22 million people that'll help
that's exactly right so
um I think it goes back to a couple
years ago right um when I I was
um put on air to talk about uh the world
had gone sideways and we were talking
about anxiety about his anxious and
stressed and burned out because we're
all locked in our homes and we threw
that quick readout uh redefining anxiety
just a quick little hey guys this isn't
the problem and that resonated so well
and anxiety is the symptom that's
exactly right and we thought that when
we opened things back up and we got back
to quote unquote normal we'd all be good
and it feels like things have continued
to Cascade sideways everybody if you
look at the data everybody's anxious
burned out stressed out I tell audiences
half of you are struggling with anxiety
and the other half of you are married to
somebody who is right yeah so
everybody's cooked and so really looking
at anxiety is not the problem anxiety is
the symptom anxiety is the alarm system
so if you're going to solve it if you're
going to build a non-anxious life you
have to actually go to the source that's
right you don't just take the batteries
out of the alarm that's right you got to
go to the source and it is what's
causing it it's about building a
different life man we are living lives
that are not free we're not dealing with
reality we have ignored our health we
have ignored
um our relationships we're just a mess
we're untethered mess and so this book
was really me walking through this
myself right
um what are the how can I distill down
the Neuroscience how can I distill down
the the the the ancient wisdom that you
get in the Bible how do I distill all
this down to six daily choices that a
person can make every day to build a
non-anxious life man and um I'm I'm
pretty jazzed about it pretty excited
about it yeah it and it uh the thing is
there's so it's it's this wonderful
combination of Grandmother wisdom and uh
biblical wisdom and
uh you know academic
uh
prowess I mean you know you've got the
two phds and so this stuff is not it's
not made up this is all researched and
dialed in uh very very carefully and yet
it's very accessible and very readable
that the most um the most important
thing for me was that my 13 year old son
could sit down and understand what this
book was about and I caught him reading
it the other day it lets me know dude
there's if you want to go read a bunch
of journals those journalists are out
there and for for the large swath of
America and getting to be myself
included those aren't accessible
um what's the meaning you can't
understand you can't understand them and
and if you can it's hard to apply it so
I wanted to create a book that put in
the hands of men and women fathers and
daughters and brothers and sisters how
can we change our lives and very similar
to what you've done with money which is
to take a complex zoo of of uh of a
financial system and just to still
here's how you live your life man I try
to do the same thing with the anxiety
and the burnout and the stress that
we're all feeling you know one of the
six choices is connection and
um where you've gotten I and I think the
cell phone that the smartphone has um
made it worse but we've gotten just
horrible at personal relationships yeah
having a friend that's right and staying
connected with human beings right
um borrowing a cup of sugar from your
neighbor instead of having Amazon drop
it on your front porch yeah you know and
then you have a conversation with your
neighbor and you find out oh they're
that you know their husband's been ill
you know I mean oh my gosh you find out
stuff when you actually talk to human
beings and have connection and when you
lose connection hermit is a you know
being a Hermit whether it's a
technological hermit or a real hermit
that's mental illness it's not good for
you yeah yeah it's not good for you I
had this experience recently my neighbor
um he's in his 70s he's as an old farmer
works the land and we had a bad
rainstorm and it washed out my gravel
driveway and I saw him in his tractor
grading my driveway for me didn't even
ask him to just
but listen my wife made some she's a a
world-class Gardener she she made some
some jars of pickles she made some
sourdough bread brought over some
venison that we had that we from last
season and we brought him over a basket
and he was working on his yard and I
brought Hank with me and I brought
Josephine with me and he looked at me
and he dropped his shoulders he's sweaty
as could be he came over and gave me a
big hug and I thought this is what
neighbors are supposed to be right you
helped me out I want to honor you and
your family and I honored you not I
didn't write you a check and he said I
don't want your money because I was
going to bring him cash he goes I'm not
taking your money but when we brought
him canned goods that represented time
that represented our garden love mint
something right and it was about
connection my kids got when you don't
have that that's exactly right bottom
line is the anxiety alarms are going to
go off they have to go along humans are
made to hang with humans your body knows
you're not good that men be alone right
that's right your body knows you're not
safe and now I know no matter what
happens I got a great neighbor next to
me that loves my family you're right
that's awesome yeah that's just a little
piece of this book man I'm excited about
it exactly that's one of the six choices
right to building a non-anxious like
brand new book comes out October 3rd it
goes on sale today as a pre-sale and uh
here's the thing
twenty dollars for the book and if you
buy it in pre-sale starting right now
you get seventy five dollars in free
bonus items instant access to Dr John
deloney's newest talk smoke fire and
freedom that breaks down some of the
mythology about this that we believe
about anxiety and help you reclaim your
life you get that talk right now you
also get the ebook and the audiobook of
building a non-anxious life when the
book comes out we'll send those to you
as well all of that is a 75 dollar value
all for 20 bucks and of course you get
the book too and pre-sale helps John and
it helps us with the marketing so the
more we can pre-sell the more it helps
with the best seller list
and the more it helps with the marketing
so if you want to help him out the best
way to do that is for you to get the
deal of the century 75 worth of stuff
for 20 bucks including the book and you
can pre-order starting right now Ready
set go at ramseysolutions.com jump in
our store
and ramseysolutions.com and uh get it
pre-ordered and uh really incredible
endorsements that you got from both the
Mental Health Community also some
friends that we have like Joshua Fields
Milburn over at uh at the minimalist
yeah and will guadera the world class
restaurant tour and Dr Carolina leaf and
Dr Lane Norton also Sal the Stefano some
of the greats man some great great folks
Michael Easter from Comfort crisis good
good endorsements so good book it's a
great book and really excited about this
material and get again into your all's
hands building a non-anxious life at
ramseysolutions.com jump in the store
and get it right now
[Music]
thank you
it's a competitive home buying Market
but there's a way you can get an edge
Churchill Mortgage works with you to
understand your budget and your goals
and the Churchill Mortgage home buyer
Edge offers you fast pre-approval and a
secured interest rate plus Churchill has
bumped up their seller guarantee to ten
thousand dollars giving your offer the
best chance of being accepted and
helping you win in today's market go to
churchillmortgage.com today to learn
more
[Music]
thank you
number one best-selling author of the
book own your past change your future
and the new book out today on pre-sale
Dr John deloney the new book building a
non-anxious life open phones are triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Dr John my co-host today Terry is with
us in Chicago hi Terry welcome to the
Ramsey Show hi Uncle Dave hi John hey
what's up
Yeah so basically I'm a business owner
with irregular income I am married but I
cannot unfortunately get my husband to
combine these finances
I'm aware that we do need to work
together and counseling is definitely
crucial but at this point I'm 52. and I
need to go ahead and do this on my own
I've done it before
um I did something foolish I started uh
using my credit cards again
um basically I relocated my business and
when I relocated my business I think I
kind of just kind of went over spending
um for the business and now uh the
location that I am that I'm at now uh we
are
um I think you know we're in the June
July so usually the summer months are
really slow but I didn't think that with
the relocation it would be Terry what's
your question
so the question
because I need to go ahead and start
doing this on
this on have done baby step number one
and number three multiple times but I'm
just trying to figure out what is the
best way to go about paying off my debt
um so that's pretty much what it is
um
yeah
how long you've been married
well hey we just 10 years
why is it he doesn't want to combine
finances you know what he's he's kind of
I don't know he's I can't really go off
into all of the details if I did
everybody would know who I am however
um at this point you know it's just kind
of like he just does not want to uh
combine finances he's content with just
you know giving his portion of what's uh
what we're going to pay for the home
um so I do carry part of what the
responsibility is in the home in terms
of the utilities I'm sorry I can't I
can't go along with this I don't I don't
I agree I'm I'm not going to participate
in this insanity
I I agree I agree this is unhealthy and
you know it's unhealthy and you refuse
to deal with it why oh I'm definitely
trying to deal with it no you're not
trying to deal with it you're trying to
work around it
um
um you know we
I can't really tell you everything but
at the end of the day I'm I'm feeling
stuck
um and I don't want to feel stuck I feel
like I want to do this with him but I
know I'm going to have to just do it on
my own for my on my portion
um so here's the thing you you let's
take that track you know how you know
what to do you put your deaths in in
order smallest to largest and you pay
them off
but you've got to so that the math
problem is simple you're too smart you
know that
I say I think you're asking Dave and I a
different question
um no uh what it is I don't the amount
of money that I have saved uh is not
equal to it's not equal to what I need
to pay things off
um but here's the thing you've got two
big messes I don't it I think you're
talking around the bush about your
business I don't think your business is
is as successful as you thought it was
going to be
and I think you have to make some hard
some hard choices about your business
and your marriage is at that 10-year
Mark and there's a seven to ten year
window when people start to open their
eyes and they exhale and they realize
this is the way this is gonna be
and we need to have some hard
conversations about what comes next or
we have to make peace with this is the
way this is but Dave said it right
you're you are accepting in rhetoric you
are not accepting this in reality
because reality says I'm gonna turn on
all the lights I'm gonna stop the music
and I'm gonna tell my significant other
the the marriage we've built thus far
ends today will you build something new
with me
and they call that vulnerability and
it's got vulnerability's got this great
um cachet about it and it's wonderful
and great except that vulnerability
means somebody may hurt you and he may
look at you and say I will not be a part
of a marriage where I'm going to be all
in with you and you have to deal with
that reality and you're not
that's a scary place to be but that's
the truth of the matter
and you and I'm not saying you got to
end your marriage you may have to say
okay fine I'm all on my own inside my
own house that's what she is saying
acquiesced I mean she gave up
and says I want to go work this by
myself and the problem is your
probability of Building Wealth when your
spouse is not participating is very low
it's hard you might clear out you might
clear out the debt but the number of
times that we interviewed millionaires
ten thousand one hundred sixty seven of
them that they said I did this while
dragging my spouse kicking and screaming
all the way and became a millionaire
anyway when they didn't participate they
didn't help I basically had a roommate
and a joint venture not a marriage
and the number of times that that
happens statistically in the data is
almost never I mean it's a it's way less
than five percent yeah and so what
you're asking to do is um statistically
improbable
a can it be done well good Lord yeah I'm
almost anything can be done but it's
just it's unhealthy because now what
we're saying is we're just going to put
our hands over our ears and go la la la
la la la la la la la and pretend like
this is not going on and we're going to
go on about our way and we're going to
try to be try to be wealthy anyway we're
gonna try to get out of debt and stay
out of debt anyway but something else is
going on here that y'all really need to
get the bottom of for the sake of your
marriage also for the sake of your
futures if you find so let's let's go to
the end let's if you find yourself in
your and the person you're married to
says I'm out I'm not doing this
I'm not recommending you then you run to
divorce court yes that's not the way to
go but then you're going to follow the
baby steps the way you follow the baby
steps and you're going to have to create
a life where I may have to go get second
jobs I may have to go get third jobs I
may have to figure this thing out and
you may have to go to counseling on your
own if the person just refuses to go
with you
um but my hope is that someone would see
your determination they would see the
path you're taking and see the light
that's coming on in your eyes and they'd
say hey I want to be a part of that I
know that's not true if you're married
to someone who struggles with addiction
if you're married to somebody who just
doesn't care someone's struggling with
certain kinds of mental I get all that
but at some point you either have to say
hey this is it we're going to have this
final conversation and if they won't do
it I mean they won't do it
um
yeah Dave sometimes it's throwing your
hands up and saying ah whatever it's not
worth it and sometimes I mean you're
just I mean the old ball and chain is
the old ball and chain you're married to
a guy that just says I ain't getting off
the couch
um and then you got some hard choices to
make I guess yeah that's where you're
facing and so I'm just telling you that
in doing this in spite of your spouse
folks
um and everything's staying separate a
it's a lot harder and B your
probabilities just not there uh and then
what we're dealing with is the money
problems are not a problem they're a
symptom of your relationship problems
that's what's going on and I I think
it's important to double click on that
um if somebody won't work with you your
biggest issue in your life is not your
debt that's what I'm trying to say your
biggest issue is you've got a marriage
that's that's sick and that is falling
apart and that is slowly killing both of
you yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because
again him's refusing to put your money
together is not a a philosophical stand
it's a relational spear through the
heart right he's throwing darts or
somebody who's in and you know another
thing Dave we we're saying I don't trust
you well I was gonna say it may be that
this is the third or fourth time you've
moved your business and gone back on
credit cards and he's saying hey I'm not
I'm not hit you in my wagon you're out
of control I'm not trustworthy and so
maybe it's about you coming to the table
and saying hey I've been struggling I
haven't been right with this stuff I'm
willing to change will you join me right
and that's almost always the best way to
approach it but
um and he may be watching you be a train
wreck over there and going I don't want
to ride on that thing I don't want to be
on that train that's right that's right
that may be the way you solve it but
anyway yeah that the thing is you need
to get up under this thing and solve
that part of it for the quality of life
that you have on going forward and uh
you know for your relationship to
prosper and then for your money to
prosper they very seldom are not
connected right these are not
compartmentalized departmentalized
things but you can set this over here
and pretend like this other isn't
happening they are woven together
inextricably you cannot get away from it
and so it's just it's tough so I hope
you can hope you can get to the bottom
of it Terry I hope you guys can find
some peace and uh find some you know
Unity at your place this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
thank you
well you've all played the telephone
game the first person Whispers a message
to the second person who Whispers it to
the third and so on around the table
until the original message has
completely changed multiply that
confusion by a hundred if you run a
business with different software systems
that don't talk to each other that's why
there's netsuite by Oracle in the early
days of Ramsey we were using different
systems for all of our business units we
needed one single source for accurate
data netsuite was the software we used
to optimize and take us to the next
level netsuite gave us the visibility
into all of our numbers so that we could
communicate across departments and plan
ahead better and as we grew it scaled
with us next week worked for Ramsey and
it will make a difference for your
business too join the more than 34 000
customers who trust netsuite to help
make them smarter and make better
decisions and level up their operations
to learn more get a free product tour at
netsuite.com Ramsay that's netsuite.com
Ramsay
foreign
[Music]
deloney Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author is my co-host today
he's also the host of the Dr John
deloney podcast which you need to tune
into if you want to hear about
relationships and mental health issues
and all kinds of fun stuff it's an
exciting fun show there's always
something wacky going on and always good
information for you you to use in your
daily life as well
welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave how you doing today better than
I deserve what's up
good um so I have this question about I
have a 401 I changed jobs and I have a
401k sitting
um there and I'm
um very tempting to take that 401k given
that the we're moving so I'm selling my
current home moving to Phoenix
and it's very tempting to take that 401k
and take the 30 hit and put that on the
next home to drive my to so that I can
get a 15-year mortgage to kill that
upfront interest that's that's uh all
this all this front loaded interest on
these on these loans on these loans
right now and I know that's generally
not a good idea but you know with a
seven and a half percent return annually
and you're talking about six six point
five percent interest uh you know you're
gonna pay that in interest over the
course you know you're gonna that
hundred thousand dollars is gonna make
you know of roughly 450 over the course
of 20 years and you're going to pay that
roughly in interest over the course of
the loan so my question is is you know
normally I find a good idea to do but is
there an edge case where that might be
okay especially if it affords me a lot
more money to invest over time given my
monthly output
I want to borrow a 30 interest to put
more down on my house
so that I can save so I can save
interest over time no that doesn't make
sense
and are you are you on a 20 tax bracket
um almost so um so I'm I'm making a 150
years
30 tax bracket so this is not a thirty
percent it's a 40 hit
I see okay you have a 10 penalty plus
your tax hit
so it would be 40 it would be 40 yeah on
that yeah 10 plus your tax rate
so all of a sudden it gets even it gets
even more evil no we're not doing that
no I would I would stay away from that
now here and here's the other thing the
other piece of information you've got
that's wrong somehow is that mortgages
are front loaded with interest they're
not
they're not okay you pay more interest
on the front end because a an
amateurization has a level payment and
the portion of your payment that goes to
interest goes down as the balance goes
down
and so there is more interest on the
front end but it's not front loaded it's
calculated on the outstanding balance
so there's not a front yeah okay I guess
30 years 30 years or an extra 15 years
of interest payments yes and yes we
don't want to do 30 years but it's not
front loaded with interest it's it's the
interest is calculated on the
outstanding balance on all mortgages
except for some kind of subprimes
garbage but I mean a traditional
conventional mortgage is calculated like
simple interest
so in that case I guess it would be
better to take that 401k and either roll
it over into an IRA or into my current
401K roll it to an Iowa and then and
then yeah and then just uh make uh take
whatever money we get from the house and
buy a house that you can put on a
15-year
yeah buy a house so we can put on a
15-year that yeah I guess that's
probably the better way that's gonna
yeah that's gonna be at the end of the
story the biggest pile of wealth
I mean that's my ultimate goal is
because the current house that I have
now is on 30 it was on 30 year because I
didn't have a lot of money saved
whenever I bought the house but I sent
uh since paid off a good like I paid off
all my school loans I don't have any
credit card debt the only other debt I
have is just my truck which is uh I owe
17 000 on my truck but that's that's it
like I never I don't have any other debt
other than that okay well it's a good
thing let's get that cleaned up they're
standing between you and wealth too
yeah and there's also a third thing here
Dave and I always
um a light bulb goes off for me when
somebody paints an either or picture
either I cash out this 401 to do X or I
just got to pay this thing out over 30
years there's always a third option and
the third option here is no pay extra on
that loan and buy a house you can a four
dollar fifteen don't don't pet it for 15
years get rid of it in seven get rid of
it in six right exactly um don't just
sit on it right and so then that all
those calculations you're doing the back
of a napkin that a were incorrect but B
feel like they make sense they don't
make they don't make sense if you just
get rid of the loan completely yeah the
loan's gonna be gone anyway paid off
yeah pay it off so if the typical
millionaire pays off their home in the
study that we did in 11.3 years
okay the that's the average uh and the
average millionaire in the study that
was following the Ramsey stuff does it
in one year soon or 10.2 years and so a
lot of people a lot do it in Seven
what's your what you're describing John
and but you do that based on the home
you purchase and so you're not maxing
out the we're gonna get the biggest
possible home that anyone will loan us
enough money to do on any kind of so
we're going to get a 30-year adjustable
rate maxed to the wall because we're
going to get the biggest part that does
not work no you know so you're buying a
more modest home you're stepping back to
do this and do it right and that's the
smart way to do it also one of the most
important the news is Sam you're asking
the questions and you're thinking yeah
yeah good for you man one of the most
important things you wrote in baby step
millionaires I think one of the biggest
takeaways that it was an aha moment for
me was a million dollars is not a
billion and we get this idea of a
millionaire is like I'm gonna be able to
no it takes 10 years it's a long time
most people takes a long time relax
relax takes a long time and it's
frustrating and it's slow and if you can
speed it up awesome but it's not about
getting a billion dollars and being able
to pay off everybody's houses and buy a
bunch of no man it's about discipline
over time yep Elizabeth's in Atlanta hi
Elizabeth how are you I'm great thank
you so much for taking my call this is a
huge honor to be able to speak to you
guys our honor as well how can we help
well my daughter sweet little girl just
graduated from college in May and she's
living in the big city 12 hours away and
Saturday I got a call saying mommy they
ran my card my debit card for my whole
balance that was in my savings account
because it is to connect her checking is
connected to her savings and she was
freaking out and wondering what to do
and so I'm sorry who did what do you
mean they ran who's there a merchant a
merchant ran her card
and took her debit card and took all of
her money out of it yeah it she had like
38 3800 for a thousand dollars in the
account and they ran it for 30. so they
stole her money
so they put it back
okay all right so what's the problem
well see now because they've she's done
that or that happened to her she was
without that funds and those funds until
it until it it posted to her account on
two that yesterday and so her her now
she's wanting to get a credit card and
I'm trying to tell her that that's not
the what she needs to do she has no debt
she has no here's what she needs to do
disconnect your freaking savings account
from your checking account
Tada now we're safe every time I get a
flat tire I don't get rid of cars and go
back to riding a horse
I had a thing it stinks but doing
something that I know is going to get me
in trouble statistically this did not
expose that the debit card is a problem
and expose that she has her savings
account attached to her debit card
that's what it exposed yeah yeah I've
never had that happen because I don't
have that
and I've had debit cards since they came
out 25 years ago well that was gonna be
my question she you know she uses her it
runs as a
um overdraft protection so you know you
don't have overdraft protection hey you
know what overdraft protection is
balance your freaking checking account
hey Elizabeth here's the bigger question
how do you convince your daughter who
just graduated college and who's making
her way in the world to do a thing and
that you can't you can't so you used to
be able to tell her what to do now you
have to sit down over coffee and say hey
I don't think this is a great decision
here's some decisions we've made where
it's backfired on me and our family and
then you got to hold her hand while she
goes and has to learn some things the
hard way yeah yeah and
this did not expose the weakness of the
debit card system it exposed the
weakness of your daughter's system that
that's the thing she needs to get if she
gets that it'll she'll be convinced
this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
Dr chandeloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today thanks for joining us open
phones at triple eight eight two five
five two two five hey if you are a new
listener out there and you want to know
kind of where you fit into all this
stuff there's a free thing you can do at
ramseysolutions.com it's the GSA the get
started assessment click the get started
button and we'll help you figure out
where you are and what your next steps
are be sure and click it there at
ramsaysolutions.com Sam is with us in St
Louis hey Sam welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey how are you guys better than we
deserve sir how can we help
so I am 26 years old I've been listening
to you guys kind of on and off for a few
months I'm actually in the industry uh I
work in wealth management
um I have no debt I'm just kind of
curious what your advice to a 26 year
old who really doesn't have a need for a
house but has a little bit of money
um kind of need a car here soon but I'm
just kind of feeling a little stuck with
all the options so I wanted to get
y'all's thoughts good for you well done
what do you make
uh 56 000 that's before
um any bonus or anything total it's
probably around 63.64. okay very good
good start man well done well you're
right we would first have an emergency
fund of three to six months of expenses
in liquid cash meaning some kind of high
yield savings account money market type
thing right just sitting there just for
emergencies uh and then I'd have a car
fund or saving to pay for cash for this
next car and once that's maxed out then
I think you're probably Building Wealth
for and I'd be doing that while I'm
saving fifteen percent of my income into
retirement so I'll be in your 401k or
Roth IRAs and good growth stock mutual
funds fifteen percent of your income
going into that and and then beyond that
since you don't have a house and don't
have a need or want for a house today I
would start building a house fund
because long term you do want to be an
owner in the real estate business
because one hundred percent of the time
rents go up over time
and so your largest line item in your
budget is housing
and it's going to go up every year until
you become an owner
so it's not it's not the end of the
world if you want to go for the next
four or five years and be a runner
that's fine but don't go 40 years
because ask people ask people what real
estate costs 40 years ago you know it's
a different thing right right right and
that's kind of kind of where I guess I'm
a little feeling a little stuck is I'm
taking six percent getting that match
um out of my 401k and then I'm only
living off of
um 65 of the rest so I'm immediately
saving 35 good for you yeah you're a
natural saver yeah so let's make sure
you're getting a full 15 into retirement
of your income and then let's make sure
the emergency fund's in place and the
car funds going beyond that I'm gonna
just start take take something like an S
P 500 fund and start throwing money in
it and then about four years from now
five years from now maybe you've met
someone maybe you're married you're in a
position you got a couple hundred grand
laying there and you can buy a house or
put down a huge downstroke on a house
one of the two and that gets you ready
you just don't want to be out of the
real estate market permanently as a home
owner it doesn't bode well for it
destabilize this is your retirement
years to to not be the owner of the
property you're in it adds
as anxiety John yeah there's something
about owning your house free and clear
that that wipes a lot of that anxiety
off the table Yeah his new book goes on
has gone on sale today building a
non-anxious life and you know an element
of you know we call it Financial Peace
you know when you don't have any debt
and you you know so someday Sam you own
a paid for property as a part of your
wealth mix it adds peace to your life
that's exactly right yeah
now Devin is in Columbia South Carolina
hi Devin welcome to the Ramsay show
hi thank you sure what's up
um so I am trying to figure out how to
get out from underneath of a land loan
that we had purchased a few weeks or a
few years ago or I guess about a year
and a half ago did you say hey land loan
yes we bought 27 acres of land hoping to
build a home
uh life change that didn't happen prices
were ridiculous for what we were trying
to do and we weren't trying to build
anything crazy just to we were a growing
family and wanted land um but it didn't
work out and we decided to just go with
a different home and now we're just
trying to saw the land and I'm having a
hard time getting it sold
um how long has it been on the market
it's been listed since about March of
this year what are you asking for it
uh one
47 5 is what the latest listing prices
and what do you owe on it
uh about 90. and what'd you pay for it
110 and we'd put down about 20 000 cash
okay you paid 110 and you're asking 147
and you've owned it how long
since December of 2021. so what makes
you think it went up thirty seven
thousand dollars during that time
so you guessed
yeah and now you've got your Landover
priced and you're bitching because it
didn't sell
[Laughter]
I've looked at per acre size in the area
and and right now most per acre in the
area
asking or sold well and that somebody
just asked me that yesterday and I don't
I'd have to ask anything you never you
never use asking price for appraisal
there's idiots asking all kinds of
things out there but if there's actual
sales in the area of similar sized
tracks at eleven thousand dollars an
acre then you have an appraisal item
that you can use the data to appraise
but I I shopped around and somebody said
somebody sold it no no no no I want to
know what it really sold for I want do
you have a real estate agent
we do and he's he's great no he's not
he hasn't he hasn't informed you of your
price
and how how to price it he priced it the
way you told him to price it that's not
his job his job is to tell you what your
actual value is and not take a listing
that's overpriced because what he's
going to end up with is a dissatisfied
customer because he hasn't been able to
sell her property because he allowed her
to price it too high maybe I don't know
I think you did though you're probably
right now I think you're doing that yeah
I think we figured out why it hadn't
sold drop your price I mean find out
what it's really worth Maybe I'm Wrong
let's find out what it's really worth
though actual data and call your real
estate agent say I didn't know what this
is really worth and I'm not paying for
an appraisal you dig up some comps and
let's figure out what this thinking
thing's worth and your real estate agent
not able to do that in about an hour and
if they you know know how to basically
run the MLS computer and then uh then
you can figure out if you've got
overpriced and price it right okay you
can't
you know this Market has slowed down and
people overpaying for stuff because
they're in a Feeding Frenzy is over
that's done nobody there's very few
markets that are doing that there's some
kind of 83 offers over the weekend crap
that stuff's gone okay apparently we've
kind of gone back to more of a normal
real estate world where stuff stays on
the market three to four months if
priced properly and you don't get to
price it like you wish
you could and if there's any this is
purely anecdotal
um but there's a lot more signs in the
rural area where I live for 15 Acres or
20 acres or 30 acres and they're just
all still sitting out there and there
was a season a year ago when you
couldn't run fast enough over there to
get it there was no signs they never
went to Market and so I don't think we
had a 37 increase in Columbia South
Carolina in raw land prices in in one
year yeah and that's what she's
proposing you know if we did if you have
a loan that you need to get rid of you
price it right you price it right and
get rid of it yeah yeah because every
month you're sitting there paying it you
just become a motivated seller right you
know so yeah if I'm in your issues Devin
I'm gonna get to the bottom of this if
you're real estate agent can't then get
a new real estate agent and let's let's
find out what it's actually worth and
let's price it a little bit below that
let me ask you this a guy who sold and
bought a lot of properties
um let's say I bought a I bought a
bought a piece of land for 100 grand
like she did 110 Grand it's priced at
137 but I need this loan gone would you
ever drop it to what I paid for it to or
you know 116 to get my money and just
get ready at what I no I mean there's no
it's not being repo she's not in the
Panic okay just motivated yeah I just
want to get rid of it so let's price it
properly okay and it'll sell within you
know 90 days if it doesn't drop it a
little more it'll sell you'll get rid of
it this is the Ramsay show thank you for
joining us America
[Music]
thank you
hey it's Dr John deloney if you like
what you heard in this episode and want
to know more about getting started on
the Ramsay baby steps go to
ramseysolutions.com and click on the get
started button we'll help you figure out
the best next step for you based on your
specific situation that's
ramsesolutions.com and click get started
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting for the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships thanks for
joining us America Dr John deloney
Ramsey personality is my co-host today
he's a number one best-selling author of
the book own your past change your
future host of the Dr John deloney show
and today we are launching his latest
book on pre-sale it comes out on October
3rd you can buy it today beginning today
on pre-sale thousands of you already
have thank you pretty amazing the new
book is building a non-anxious life now
we did a quick read
a chapter book we call them they're like
37 pages in other words uh on called
redefining anxiety 150 000 of you bought
that so far uh that you know it's a ten
dollar quick thing on on the way anxiety
really works because anxiety is
everywhere John it's a real issue that's
right and we have a culture that's
designed to try to stop anxiety and
that's as smart as going into your house
and taking all the smoke detectors off
the wall and the ceiling and putting
them in a drawer and thinking your house
is somehow now safer and better off than
it was before anxieties almost never the
problem it's always an alarm it's the
alarm that lets you know hey something
in your house is on fire right and so
actually
um Dr Wendy Suzuki who's a researcher at
NYU she she calls anxiety she says
anxiety is your friend it's there to
help you out
um I may not go that far because I've
been I've been I've been beat up with it
pretty bad but
um it is something trying to get your
attention and so telling you something's
wrong that's right so if you want to
have a not stressed out out not over
anxious not burned out life you got to
change some things in your home you
gotta change some things in your life
and the alarms will quit ringing man
when there's no fire no smoke the alarms
go off yeah and there's six daily
choices you talk about in the book to do
that one of those is connection where
we've lost relationships in this country
and in this world a lot of them have
been lost to the cell phone
um I actually was making fun of some of
our friends at lunch today uh four
ladies that have lunch today together
every day down here I sat down at their
table and all four of them are sitting
there on their phone
and I'm like y'all y'all are awful I
mean you are they said well we're
talking and I'm like you're texting
across the table how are you talking I'm
looking all four of you have your nose
and your phone and they well we were
talking a few minutes ago and you know
but we've lost the ability to have
relationships
there's actually some research that
suggests just having the phone on the
table
within within uh an ability to see it
right I'm not touching it it's just
sitting on the table actually causes the
interaction to decrease it it's somebody
knows somebody else could come at any
moment right and it's just an
intervention we're just an interruption
away that's right
um one of the things you would also talk
about is Health yeah health and healing
yeah sometimes as a choice yeah
sometimes uh you know let me let me be
honest it's not a popular conversation
to have
um but we've reached a point in our
culture where we're sick we're sick
we're sick we're not well
um we're struggling with our weight
we're struggling with our code of
cardiovascular health we're just not
well and we're wondering why our anxiety
alarms are going off all the time or
we have seven Red Bulls and four um cups
of coffee for breakfast something wrong
with it we're wondering I'm beating out
of our chest right what's wrong with
that John I have one person that I care
about who went to see a counselor about
anxiety and the counselor said hey just
take 30 days off of uh
just drop caffeine for 30 days and there
was about a week of awful headaches
and the anxiety kind of magically went
away and so they just found out they
were super uh tall uh they were super
main lining coffee they lacked tolerance
to uh to caffeine so all to say is we
gotta take control of our health we got
to take control of dealing with our old
traumas and so that we can sit in our
present life and deal with the the chaos
that is real
um we can deal with it peacefully not as
adding chaos to chaos yeah so two of the
choices are relationships and health
that's the six choices and as you make
better choices in these daily choices in
these six areas
that cause anxiety Then the anxiety has
no reason the alarm has no reason to go
off because it's not there's nothing
there to be afraid of yeah one of the
one of the
the things that modern science has
convinced us of is that our bodies are
stupid
and that our theories are better and our
medicine is better and our
um super Atomic routines are better and
there's something about letting your
body talk to you and say hey we're not
safe right now hey we have a hundred
thousand dollars on that student loan if
we make one wrong uh move at work we're
gonna get let go and we lose the house
and we lose these cars your body's
trying to get your attention man so if
if you're a natural stress yeah if
you're Financial stress if you're not
well if you don't have any friends your
body's like Hey we're not safe we're not
safe and so instead of shutting that up
instead of climbing up in your kitchen
and taking the batteries out of the
alarm
this book is all about man how can we
reclaim our homes how can we reclaim our
families we came our bodies put the fire
out man once and for all Financial Peace
relational peace peace peace peace is
the opposite of anxious anxious
anxiousness no so there it is and
similar to the financial peace message
we have an emergency fund not if because
things will come right yeah and so we
build a non-anxious life so that when
our cousin passes away when Dad gets
sick when Mom gets cancer that we have
the capacity to go sit and be a part of
those those those life things that
happen all the time because your Tank's
full because we got that's exactly right
yeah hey all month long we're giving
away cash you could win 500 a week and
grand prize with three thousand dollars
check that out at the Ramsey
solutions.com giveaway The Total Money
Makeover from paycheck to purpose own
your past change your future Don John's
book before this one is now 12 this
month and guess what the brand new book
is twenty dollars if you pre-order it
you get 75 in free bonus items the new
book is building a non-anxious life if
you want the 75 of free bonus items all
you do is go to ramsaysolutions.com and
get the book while it's on pre-sale or
we'll ship to you the ebook to you the
audiobook to you and in the meantime we
will send you a one of John's talks and
you want to check all of that out as
well and that's all just for 20 bucks
also all questions for human
conversation cards are on sale right now
12 that's a bargain too big sale going
on right here in the middle of summer
ramsaysolutions.com store be sure you
check every bit of that out and guys if
you want to help if you're a John
deloney fan like I am and you want to
help us and and help John in the process
pre-purchasing pre-ordering the book
helps our marketing push big time
because it pretty much ensures that he's
going to be a number one best seller on
the day that the book actually launches
the pre-sales all count towards that and
so you're helping us by by going ahead
and getting it and we're bribing you to
do it we're giving you extra good stuff
not above it yeah we're not proud hey
kids
75 worth of stuff for 20 bucks here and
it helps us that's right so thank you
thank you
and by the way the book's awesome just
as an aside yeah the uh the comments
folks are sending on social media just
like they're they're putting wind in my
sales man people are sending a lot of
really great wonderful stuff it's
awesome that's very cool well I mean you
guys told us with the little uh quick
read you know redefining anxiety being
so popular that this was a subject that
John needed to go further on and so he
now he has this is a major book launch a
major book a full book not a 37 pager
this is a real one and so uh and it's
you know treats the subject beautifully
in a way that everyone can understand
and actually do it this is the Ramsay
show
[Music]
all right
if you're like most people your home is
your most valuable asset and when you
want to make improvements it can feel
like everything costs too much or takes
too long but something as simple as
custom window coverings from blinds.com
can completely change your space and add
value to your home we've recommended
blinds.com for over a decade so you know
you can trust them from blinds drapes
and shutters to motorized Shades they
make it easy and affordable to upgrade
your entire home and their team is ready
to help with everything from design
consultation to measuring and
installation plus there are never any
misleading quotes or hidden fees
everything's backed by their 100 percent
satisfaction guarantee and shipping is
always free see whyblinds.com is the
number one online retailer of custom
window coverings visit blinds.com to
save to 40 percent off everything
site-wide go to blinds.com for more
information
[Music]
[Applause]
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today Amy's in Dallas hi Amy
welcome to the Ramsay show what's up
hi
um so I have a question
um I'm the second to youngest of seven
siblings
and typically due to my financial
situation I've noticed that whenever
we're out with family events or
vacations it's kind of expected that I
pay for things oh no and
and by all means most of the time I
don't mind but when it's expected I kind
of get less Joy
out of the giving because I don't feel
like it's really giving
and this can be like you know we're out
in the city and I everyone leaves the
cab and now I'm just the last one in the
car and so of course I pay for it or
they leave the restaurant and like
thanks for lunch Amy like I didn't say I
was gonna pay for this one but I guess I
will I don't know it's
so you make more you make more than your
siblings
yes sir five by far and they decided
that means you have to pay for their
stuff
I hate that for you I hate that for you
you just don't know how to say you know
like like do I have to preface it by
saying like Hey we're gonna split the I
don't know and graded this all started I
mean I'm I'm 34 years old so it's not
like you know it's been the case forever
but this all started I think about three
years ago
um about two years after covet I guess I
don't know
um I paid for a trip to Disney World for
my whole family that's something that
I've been wanting to do since a kid and
I I was able to do it because I was
financially ready to but ever since then
it's been this
foreign
you know what I mean here's the magic
word and you're gonna hate this you
gotta make either you got to make peace
as you're the person which I don't
recommend or it's usually going to take
one or two times that you say hey
everybody's everybody's picking up their
own check on this one
um and I would not pull a fast one at a
restaurant if you've paid for the last
four or five checks I wouldn't just wait
till the waiter comes by and says uh
everybody's on a separate check I would
tell people as you're heading out and
you're gonna get one or two people who
are like oh are you serious yeah I'm
serious and at some point you just have
to draw that line and I would draw it
with a smile on my face
um and let that be and you'll find out
there's going to be one or two of your
siblings that wants nothing to do with
you because you're not their Breadwinner
anymore or they think you're oh you're
too fancy or you don't care about that's
that's on them to do that but I I would
draw that boundary with a smile and as
gently but as directly as possible up
front
in advance clearly
and and it's like you have this 30
seconds of awkwardness and then it's
over
and so I do that we do that with friends
you know like
um and so you know we're going somewhere
and we go okay guys we're picking this
part up and we're splitting the rest of
it or you know like I had a whole bunch
of my buddies golfing buddies uh went to
one of my houses to live to stay and
play golf and I'm Furnishing the house
uh so they're buying dinner
[Laughter]
I mean that's fair that's fair I mean I
got a lot more in it than they got in it
right at the end of the day you're right
so they came out pretty dadgum good so
yeah I'm like okay guys y'all figure out
when we go out to the internet who's
paying because you're treating me and
can I say this and I just laugh about it
and it's over and they're cool
mile near they're cool they're mine
they're mine at all nobody I don't say
nobody very few people love 100 free
ride and so if if even if Dave is is
paying for the hotel and he says Dylan
will you grab my bags yes I get to do
something right like there's I get some
skin in the game here or if Dave's
covering this and this and this hey
y'all covering dinner you think God yes
I'm all in like I want to be able to
jump I jumped on things yes and you know
what that but all it is you just said up
front you don't wait until you get over
at the restaurant and go hey guys I'm
gonna do an announcement here in the
restaurant you know that's just weird
and so no we'll just talk about it you
know on the car ride over we go hey by
the way guys here's why we're doing this
this week or even before we go on the
trip I'm gonna cover the houses on me
you know you know and y'all don't have
any rent and so you're buying my food if
everybody's coming to the city I'll pick
up all the cabs we're gonna everybody's
gonna pick up their own check for dinner
y'all figure it out but I'm not in and
so I I am not here to take it I mean Amy
what do you do for a living
I'm an engineer and my husband's an
engineer as well so yes we're part of
the standard I was going to say you're
also uh super gifted at hard
conversations huh they don't they don't
have that class in the engineering
curriculum right
In fairness I shifted more to the
business side so now I have I am in that
role now okay so I don't mind having it
it's just it's it's the fact that I
would I would love to pay for it when
it's not expected because I like to do
that I would love to pay for it when I
want to pay for it exactly otherwise the
love is gone hey can I tell you another
thing um
one time I I had a pretty significant
accomplishment it was an academic thing
and one of my advisors took me and my
wife out her and her husband took me and
my wife out this is one of my big like
big faux pas I was young and I was kind
of brash and idiot and I
she took us out as a celebration for an
accomplishment and I snuck around and
gave the waiter my debit card
and when the bill came it was already
paid I saw the look on my advisor's face
and it was one of sadness I had taken
her opportunity to give me a gift away
and I tell you that to tell you
sometimes people just get in this rut of
I'm just going to do it this way I'm
going to do it this way I'm going to do
it this way let let people carry their
own weight so letting people carry their
own weight sometimes is a gift to them
yeah just all you got to say about 30
seconds of awkward it's over now we've
got Clarity yeah it's easy and we move
on and five out of the seven of them
will be like that's cool and two of them
are six out of seven and then the rest
of them will smack the one that's
whining that's right you know shut up
she bought it she took us to Disney shut
up we're buying dinner that's right shut
up that's fair you know that's cool and
so that that is fair and when the joy
comes back once a year you might want to
pick up the whole tab it's great it's
okay but you say you know hey I I want
to take everybody to dinner in advance
and we booked the dinner and it's preset
that I'm doing this as a gift
this is not the normal rhythm of things
right we're discussing the difference
ahead of time and the normal rhythm of
things is you pay your own way we go you
know we we split the bill you know and
so forth so uh you know that that you
don't know well it takes
when you run around with people whether
it's family or friends that start having
an expectation that you're paying for
everything
it uh damages the relationship every
time 100 of the time so that you're
going to end up with damaged
relationships if you don't deal with
this tiny little thing and the other
side of that is if you have a family
member or a friend that picks up the tab
always offer and always make sure you
got money in your pocket to cover yours
yeah and don't ever get in that
entitlement syndrome like oh they're
paying they're paying their pain they're
paying always be ready to carry your
load man yeah exactly open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Colton is in Dallas hi Colton how
are you
good how are you guys better than I
deserve what's up
so I just have a question for you is it
should it's should I pay my house off
sooner than I you know early is my
question and so
earlier than the the mortgage sure that
all fast as you can
okay how much do you owe on your house
I owe 420 000. how much do you have in
the bank
about 650 000. paid off today
congratulations you're a homeowner why
did you why did you not pay it off to
start with
you know because I hear from people
they're like hang on to your cash cash
is King yada yada
and so right yeah you don't want to
listen to people
if you listen to the masses you'll soon
find out that the m is silent
okay and I mean I'm 24 so like I'm young
and I'm like geez I don't know what I
should do yada yada so yeah I appreciate
it yeah if you let me tell you as we
studied millionaires the data tells us
two primary things cause the cause the
typical person to become the to get
their first one to five million dollars
in net worth okay one is steadily
investing in their 401k and Roth IRA and
good growth stock mutual funds
retirement plan okay and two is a paid
off home
and those are people that have a million
dollars or more that we interviewed
they're not broke people so hey by the
way you can have a paid off house and
two hundred thousand dollars in the bank
you're 24. this is awesome you've you're
amazing touchdown congratulations fight
the ball do the Super Bowl end zone
dance right now this is the Ramsay show
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
hey guys being free to make your own
medical decisions is a big deal these
days Christian Healthcare Ministries
gives members the freedom to choose the
doctors and providers they want without
the frustration of worrying about
networks and with no waiting period to
join it's a membership-based non-profit
Ministry where hundreds of thousands of
Christians share funds to pay for and
pray for each other's medical bills for
over 40 years chm has helped families
living across all 50 states so cfchm
could be right for your family check out
more today at
chministries.org budget
[Music]
thank you
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today his new book on sale
pre-sale today it comes out October 3rd
the new book is building a non-anxious
life check it out at
ramseysolutions.com Sarah is in
Nashville hey Sarah welcome to the
Ramsay show
how are you better than I deserve how
can we help today
I'm kind of in a financial crisis and
I'm not really sure what to do
um my house is in the process of being
foreclosed on oh my and I don't know if
I should
just throw in the towel or fight so my
husband
I lost my husband four years ago and
we've been surviving off the Social
Security and insurance payments and um
the insurance company filed an appeal
and froze the payments
the beginning of the year and it just
through my finances in a
Whirlwind and I went back to work
how old was your husband
he was 36. what happened
he was working for a roofing company
in Hendersonville
and he fell through a skylight working
on a roof 30 feet
I'm so sorry and um
he suffered a cerebral hemorrhage and
the insurance company that was what
workers comp or liability insurance for
the for the employer says they're not
liable
yeah they filed an appeal and you have
an attorney
I have one through workman's comp and
they have denied the appeal and
restarted my payments
but that put me in a place where I got
behind really behind and then by the
time I got a job I was I was drowning
yeah so do they have they set a date on
your foreclosure
um September the 17th okay
so we get a little time we got a little
action here we got 45 days to work on
this that's good news what is your home
worth
375. and what do you owe on it
64. okay you are not getting foreclosed
on
breathe
I know how to stop I mean I know this is
my fault it's okay it's not your fault
nope no it's not your fault life has
happened to you you've had a tragedy
honey
and was it called the best discipline
so to start with I Want You to Breathe
this in
100 I've been doing this for 30 years
you are not getting foreclosed on
okay we're not going to allow you to
lose that much equity
we have our ways okay we're not gonna do
this okay so you're you're you're okay
now do we have some problems that we
need to address yes
okay we do but you're not going to lose
this house
I'm a hundred percent sure of it okay Do
You Believe Me Do You Believe Me
okay it's my job to do this it's all I
know how to do and I'm the best in the
world at it okay you're not gonna lose
this house now
so you've been living for three or four
years off of insurance payments you were
not working before he passed is that
right no that's correct so how old are
you
I'm 40. and what is your new job
[Music]
okay and what do you make
uh
twenty dollars an hour okay good good
and you're getting 40 or more hours
yes correct okay
so can you do a budget and eat on that
and pay your house payment if you were
current
okay all right how much is your house
payment
600 okay and how many house payments
behind are you
um
five five okay so you need three
thousand dollars to get current plus
some fees right
right okay that's correct okay all right
do you own anything
two cars you still got his own car
no my car got repoed last month
okay all right how are you uh do you
have a car at all
and so you don't have anybody around you
and family and things do you
how awesome my father six months before
I lost my husband okay
how many how many kids you got
four okay how old are they
um 2017 eight and six okay good
all right
um are you involved in a church locally
no okay all right so here's what we're
gonna do okay we're gonna wrap our arms
around you and make sure you're okay and
we're gonna put a bunch of people in
your life and um you're gonna follow the
instructions of these people and we're
gonna save your house and we're gonna
get you back up on your feet and get
your car and get you going again okay
all right we've got we've got Ramsey
counselors right here in your town we're
we're in your town and we'll use one of
our on staff people to take care of you
okay her name is Lisa and Austin's gonna
hook you up with her and she's going to
get in touch with the mortgage company
and um this is taken care of we're going
to take care of it okay and we're also
going to get you connected to a local
church and get you some help and get
some people around you because you need
some Community loving you well you've
been doing all this by yourself and it's
terrifying
idiots yeah
you're gonna be okay
I just want to do it the right way and
teach my kids the right way yeah
well honey it's hard what's your I don't
know if there's a right way to lose your
husband when he's 36.
I don't think there's a right way to do
that it's just hurts and it's messy and
then everything gets discombobulated
can I tell you one of the greatest gifts
you can give your kid right now
all four of us
you can let them know that they're not
crazy and that you miss their dad too
when they get to see mom cry and they
get to see Mom go get a job and they get
to see Mom do the unthinkable which is
reach out for help which is something
that Sarah does not like to do
when they get to see that they get to
see what it looks like when a grown-up
gets hit with everything
and they get to see a community rally
around and they begin to regain their
faith in humanity the light comes back
on a little bit and they get to see that
by watching their mom go through it
and so you you feel like you're failing
them you feel like you're failing
everybody it's all coming down on you
I want you to know you're changing your
family tree because they're getting to
see a strong mom say enough I can't do
any more we can somebody help me they
get to see that in real time and you're
gonna have to follow these steps the
hard work is just beginning right but
they're gonna get to watch their mom
reach out they're gonna watch their mom
walk back in the doors of a church and
say I can't do this by myself anymore
they're going to watch their mom
um say hey kids I gotta go to work
they're gonna get to watch their mom do
all that
and they're going to take those lessons
into their families
okay I just want to make them proud yeah
oh you are trust me you are the fact
that you're standing and breathing
you're making them proud on top of what
Dave just said I'm gonna throw in our
friends at better help I'm gonna throw
in three months or six months of free
counseling for you okay
thank you and hang on the line here at
uh Austin will get you connected with
our friends at betterhelp and they have
been great great partners with me and
the Ramsey Show here and they're going
to take care of you for the next six
months okay
you can do that from your phone you can
do it from your computer we got you what
kind of mortgage is this FHA VA or
conventional
I think it's uh I know it's an arm
but I think it's a conventional because
who has the mortgage who's the mortgage
company
Americus
oh okay good good good good good okay
that's wonderful you're just giving me a
hard time about everything because I'm
not on the mortgage but I'm authorized
on it yeah they don't have any choices
here okay there are laws and regulations
and things that are they they think
they're in control of this they're not
Sarah I wish you could watch this Dave
just gave the smile when Dave gives the
smile crap's about to get done
hang on uh awesome to pick up we'll get
you taken care of kiddo this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
Dr Sean deloney Ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
our question today comes from neighborly
your hub for Home Services when you need
to make repairs schedule routine
maintenance or find local help for Home
Improvement projects neighborly is your
source for Reliable home service
providers in your area go to
neighborly.com to start your search all
right today's question comes from
Anthony in North Carolina Anthony writes
just started listening to your show I'm
42 and divorced and have 73 500 bucks in
Consumer Debt after making minimum
payments rent and child support I have
about 900 bucks left over it seems like
it will take me six plus years to get
this mess cleaned up another one plus
years to build an emergency fund and
then two to three more years to save for
a house at that point I'll be 53 years
old I have zero savings for retirement
it's overwhelming and I feel hopeless my
question is how do I hold on to hope as
I work through this debt
hmm
well I mean in six years you'll be done
I know that's a lot of hope I mean if
you don't do this in six years you're
going to still be screwed
so that's hope number one uh Hub number
two is uh sell a car because it's
probably forty thousand of the seventy
thousand and you're strutting around as
a divorcee in a car you don't need
uh I'm guessing but I could not there's
a possibility I've done this before
maybe sell the house or maybe or maybe
work all the time take three jobs
instead of watching Netflix yeah and
brooding
um redefine yourself as a person who
works all the time because you ain't got
nothing else to do and it's kind of good
for you when you're uh when you got the
blues and you've been through heartbreak
and heartache and engage and all the
things that go with divorce and uh just
go work like a maniac and let's turn the
six years into two
or sell the car and turned it into one
or something like that that's how you do
it uh you chain what are the variables
what you know Henry Cloud talks about
your desired future what must be true
okay what must be true for this six
years to turn into two we sell some
stuff and we work more right you can
only make more money or spend less money
that's it right yep and um
and I'm not sure we've done this budget
properly either we'll keep working on
the budget too but you know what else is
going on you got a big tax refund uh
because you got too much coming in your
check and so we change your check and oh
now there's two thousand dollars a month
coming in because we used to get a ten
thousand dollar tax refund
we changed another 800 bucks a month
when we do that I don't know when we get
down into your deal but
uh
there's never one set of facts there's
never a singular path is the only path
and you've laid this out as if this is a
in a fatalistic way as if as if this is
the only method
your method and it takes six years and
that that terrifies me or let this be
the slowest method you laid it all out
if nothing changes then nothing changes
then in 10 years I'll be ready to buy a
house yeah
um then let's say okay cool game on how
can I cut this 10 years down to three
how can I cut this ten years down to
five ten years down to four two one get
after it yeah yeah so I'm telling you 73
consumer that there's a car in there I
might be wrong maybe wrong but um
it could be just stuff that's all left
over from the divorce it could be a
bunch of medical and all student loan
and you know old Irish debt or something
like that I don't know what it is but um
yeah this sounds like somebody who
yeah I mean the the this question is
somebody sitting in a pile of what could
have been and what I thought was going
to happen and it's not and it it does
feel defeatist and you're looking at the
math you're like this just this is my
life on top of the divorce on top of the
losing my kids on top of all this stuff
um and there's something about getting a
couple people around you standing up and
dusting the Ash off yourself and then
getting after it man yeah there's what's
the other option right what's the other
option
Netflix and booze like right what's the
other option yeah and and
I if I don't like what the deal is
change the change the deal change the
deal I don't like the secure change it
by changing something else change change
your income change your outgo change
where you're running you know do
something bizarre and outrageous if you
want outrageous results you have to do
outrageous things right
and uh if you want normal results do
normal things right and that's true in
almost anything you have to you know you
have to go at it baby I mean add it it's
game on and so uh but here the the truth
is is that you've been through one of
the most devastating
events that a human can go through a
divorce
it emotionally guts you it is a form of
trauma agreed absolutely and your
heart's broken the wind is out of your
sails your you know you're you're you
don't have the Swagger you had what you
thought for your life is now different
it's over right you have to change the
whole story and it feels like since that
sucks then I have to so if I had to
suffer there I got to suffer over here
too it's just like it starts to kind of
this uh it becomes not what happened to
me it becomes I am this exactly exactly
like I you know this is the you know my
this has redefined My Life as a disaster
I didn't experience a failure I'm a
failure right yeah that and that that's
where hopelessness comes from so
Proverbs says hope deferred
help put off makes the heart sick and
that's what hopelessness is and then it
goes on to say
but when desire comes ah there we go
when what is your desired future when
desire comes when I start to see a light
at the end of the tunnel that's not an
oncoming tray yeah when desire comes it
is the Tree of Life
and it'll light you up man and it's the
it is the power it is the truly the
power of Hope and some people do that's
not cheesy that's just factual some
people do hope with vision boards and
what what it took for me and my wife are
for really for me she just went along
with it
man was just making one of those uh
construction paper chains that little
kids use before they go on the ski trip
and just writing the numbers down but I
got to see it on the wall and every day
I got to say okay I'm headed towards
that I'm headed towards that and we tore
off a link every time we Paid a Debt off
we tore another link we turn out a link
and man we got there real real quick
because we just kept we just and we got
a second see it it wasn't this idea it
was right there
if you lean in and you do a detailed
budget and you agree with yourself I'm
gonna do whatever it takes
a hundred percent of the time I see
people do that the math quits working in
a good way it's wild you move faster
than the math told you you were going to
move every single time it's just uh
there's something about the power
momentum and when people decide when
they make a decision but it also works
the other way that if you make a
decision I'm going to sit in a hole
and play in the mud and whine about it I
mean that we can all we can all do it's
a compound interest for your life it
escalates this way but also de-escalates
that way exactly there's you can't just
kind of sit there in the middle it
doesn't work you either game on or that
you either happening to it or it's
happening to you right so Victor or
victim you are not a victim of this
situation and you rise up above it you
pounce on it you beat the snot out of it
and you change its direction and that's
that's what you can do it's doable we
see people do it all the time we know
you can too I know you can open phones
here at triple eight eight two five five
two two five thank you for joining us
we're so glad you're here this whole
money thing does revolve around
uh in a very strange way belief
is something as logical as math as
arithmetic doesn't change until you
change
and when you change your belief and you
go huh I can be a millionaire that's
what upsets me so much about people
telling people there's no hope in
America to build wealth anymore that all
the opportunity is gone and the little
man can't get ahead and people that came
from the neighborhood I came from can't
do it and whatever that neighborhood
that is everyone says that for some
reason and that's the Hope Stealers that
are out there telling people it can't be
done and that's why I did baby steps
millionaires not because I want to show
a factual uh although I did show a
factual uh uh debate on hey it is
possible and I've got all this data to
prove it's possible but I also did that
to prove to the Hope stealing to the
people who've had their hopes stolen by
The Hope Stealers that it's not so it's
believing it
is it is necessary to taking the action
that's right you will not take the
action unless you believe it and so that
that's a big deal that's a big deal
that's why we do the math we do here on
the air with you
it's very very possible
Dr John deloney Ramsey personality my
co-host today his new book building a
non-anxious life is on pre-sale right
now at ramsesolutions.com jump over
there and get a copy
[Music]
foreign
if you love the show and want a deeper
dive on your money Journey we have a
Weekly Newsletter that gives you
trending and helpful articles and tips
on following the Ramsay way just go to
ramseysolutions.com today to sign up for
our newsletter again that's
ramsesolutions.com to sign up for our
Weekly Newsletter
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studios it's the
Ramsay show where we help people build
wealth do work that they love and create
actual amazing relationships Dr John
deloney Ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book own your
past change your future and host of the
very popular podcast the Dr John deloney
show where he answers questions about
life mental health and uh relationships
brand new book going on sale today
building a non-anxious life is on
pre-sale right now it will ship October
3rd and you can get it at
ramseysolutions.com we're throwing in a
bunch of extra goodies about 75 worth of
stuff if you pre-buy it for twenty
dollars because it helps us and we
appreciate it and of course you're going
to get a lot of good fun stuff extra
stuff if you buy it early so there you
go it's kind of a fair trade open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five Alex is in North Carolina hi
Alex welcome to the Ramsey Show
hi Dave hi John thanks so much for
taking my call sure what's up
no freaking money
and I've been doing it for years uh I
just discovered your work and I've been
following it I'm on baby steps number
two
and basically since I discovered your
work Dave I mean from one day to the
next everything I bought and all all my
decisions for my reckless spending and
my bad decisions now just feels weird
and and sort of brings shame I mean I'm
driving around in the new car I bought
last year it feels weird sitting in the
expensive furniture doesn't feel right
um things I've I've bought and stuff
just makes me feel uncomfortable uh
pretty much all because I know I have
this big mess to clean up
um I think I'll be able to clean up the
mess and come out all right but I guess
my question is twofold or my number is
right and that I can clean this mess up
without changing my lifestyle too much
if I can just control my spending
behavior and secondly if I can clean it
up with my current income how do I deal
with this sort of emotionally and
psychologically kind of seeing all my
past mistakes every day in front of me
okay uh well how much debt do you have
not counting your house
80 000 okay and what is that on
uh 40 000 is my car
thirty thousand is uh student loan and
ten thousand is a credit card okay and
what do you make
uh uh 150 okay and how much money do you
have in savings not counting retirement
uh about 15K non-retirement any
non-retirement Investments at all
about 5k mutual fund
okay so we got 20K there all right cool
cool
um
like it can be done by October one
yeah yeah maybe if he sells that car
yeah sell the car and use the 20K yeah
you'll be done by Christmas yeah
so yeah this is very doable
um if you don't sell the car you'll be
done by the next Christmas
so
um 18 months you know six to 18 months
you can be done depending on whether you
want to keep the car or not
um and I think it was you yeah I think
you were talking about somebody the
other day was saying your stuff talks to
you oh yeah was that you yeah um uh don
Madsen the minimalist mom was was
introduced me to this idea that
um your things have imaginary
conversations with you all the time and
I kind of rolled my eyes when she said
it and then I got home
and I started looking around my basement
where I've got this little Jam area and
my hunting gear and all my books
and they quietly started saying hey are
you going to read us are you going to be
stupid Forever my guitars are like are
you just not going to play us just going
to be old you're gonna be that guy and
my hunting stuff was like he's gonna be
an indoor nerd now it wouldn't shut up
and so there is a an idea that at some
point I got to get rid of some of this
crap and I gotta deal with this shame
right I'm interested brother what makes
you feel this shame like you keep
talking about you don't feel comfortable
on this what is at the root of that
discomfort
Reckless Behavior
see the light now and okay what if I
just say sell it
what's your initial response like put on
today on Facebook Marketplace here is
some furniture I'm gonna sell it
what's your instant gut response
peace what are you doing man sell it
yeah sell it
are you single
uh I'm married okay yeah you probably
okay yeah
you gotta lead with that man before you
saw her couch we need to talk about this
but yeah
um so it's okay if you're uh
I mean I I have okay I owned a bunch of
property before I went bankrupt in my
20s
uh most of those houses are still
standing
so when I go out to eat and that end of
town and we drive by and go yeah I used
to own that and that house is looking at
me going yeah back when you were stupid
and that's been 35 or 40 years ago you
know and so that house is still telling
me I'm stupid or was stupid but I was
stupid back then and so you know when
you bought that you were Reckless and
it's telling you you you're you were
Reckless back then and it might be okay
if it's not weird or dysfunctional to
think have a few things reminding you
not to go back to that behavior that you
know that table says we shouldn't have
bought that and and so
um and and you know every time I eat at
it I remember not to be Reckless anymore
right so maybe it's a good reminder in a
sense a milestone a psychological or
spiritual Milestone to look but if
there's too many of these things telling
you you're stupid all day long it's the
thing is you have to make the items
behave in their message their message
has to be you used to be Reckless when
you bought me now you're not
the old me did that but the new me
doesn't do that and so if they're but if
they're telling you that you're just
you're stupid no it was stupid when I
bought you but I'm not stupid now and I
wouldn't I wouldn't buy you again and
here's what you have to do you have to
gain some confidence in this new life
and our buddy Alex hermosi I love the
way he says this to get confident you
have to practice you just gotta you
can't think your way to being confident
yeah you have to start doing it so you
need to start making a budget with your
wife every month and what you're going
to do is you're going to look up in six
months and you're gonna you're gonna owe
nobody anything you're gonna have gotten
rid of some of this stuff that's
nonsense and she might be completely at
peace or she may have like want to pull
your hair out but there's going to be
some peace in your house and then you're
going to have some confidence because
you've got some budgeting practice
you're starting to get a hang of this
thing and all of a sudden this shame
kind of evaporates because you're
walking a little bit taller and you've
leaned into this life right you know and
honestly the thing that Craig Rochelle
and James Clear both talk a lot about
too is resetting your identity yeah and
that's saying okay I am a person who is
thoughtful and wise in my purchases I'm
not a reckless person
and that's you say that's who I am now
now I used to be you know this and this
and this and I used to be the guy who
borrowed money up his eyeballs and so I
went Brokenness I started doing this
whole thing right that's me but I'm not
that guy anymore yeah I'm now Mr don't
borrow money Ramsay I mean come on hello
and there's something about sitting with
your wife and saying here's who we're
going to be are you in and then y'all
just reverse engineer and you co-create
that life together yeah and I think your
stuff will shut up when you do that it
does it'll it'll quit yelling at you
it's only yelling at you if it gets a
foothold I have one guitar that still
yells at me but all the others are good
they're all good well I you know what
Facebook Marketplace nope nope
this is the Ramsay show
foreign
[Music]
here I'm a huge fan of both meditation
and prayer and good mental health
includes slowing down gaining control of
your thoughts and plugging into
something bigger than you and Halo makes
it easy to start a daily practice of
meditation prayer and finding peace
Hollow is the number one Bible app in
the world and you can tailor content
towards your faith tradition from
scripture readings and prayers to
meditation and journaling hallow makes
it easy to practice prayer meditate and
build a deeper more meaningful spiritual
life and ReDiscover true peace go to
hollow.com Ramsay today to get three
months of hallow for free that's
hollow.com Ramsay
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
personality is my co-host thank you for
being with us America open phones at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five Lori is in Sacramento California hi
Lori welcome to the Ramsey Show
our pleasure
I'm working on baby step four and I
found myself a financial advisor and I
know he's the right one because out of
everybody I asked he's the only one that
agreed that I have to pay off my house
instead of investing more okay something
he passed that first test but my
question for you is
um I know that you have the four
categories for investing I'm 61 years
old do we need to adjust that at all for
my age I'm I'm a little bit behind so I
tend to want to kind of go a little more
aggressive to gain more or should I just
stick with the plan I would stay with
those four if it was me
um my purse I'm 63 my personal uh 401K
is in exactly that it's in those four
and then and then just to throw another
little wrench into there he's in the
process of pulling all my because I have
a various my my uh retirement accounts
are kind of spread out at different
employers she's going to pull that all
in together and I and I didn't realize
that I have kind of a big old chunk of a
single stock that's done really really
well and how much of it can I keep
is that uh in a retirement account or is
that is that just a single stock
you know it's in a retirement account
it's in my Charles Schwab an old 401k
that's rolled over okay so it was like a
company benefit of that that company
stock you work for at the time
nope nope it was just that company set
it up so that you could have an account
at Schwab and invest in any little thing
you want wow okay all right yeah I'm I'm
rolling all of that into the four types
of mutual funds in IRAs
so not I can't keep my little single
stock uh you can but uh you asked me if
I would I wouldn't yeah
what's it worth
it's right now it's worth probably about
uh uh a hundred thousand
okay and what's your total nest egg in
retirement it's about 325. yeah I
wouldn't I wouldn't have a third of my
nest egg in a single stock too much risk
for me
yeah I know you said like 10 but yeah 10
Max and that's what I would do so if you
love it and you just want to keep
messing with it then that means about 30
000 of it you could stay with but um
okay but I I I don't you know again I I
what I tell people to do is what I
actually do I don't have like one set of
thing advice for for myself and then for
everyone else I give this other advice
no I do exactly I don't own a single
single stock not one and I'm not uh so
uh because I just don't want the risk
and I don't want to screw with it I
don't get it's not fun for me
I I like to put things on I like wealth
building things to be on autopilot and
right and that's really what I want so
that's a good point and Lori I would
look at it like at some point you got to
walk away from the table in Vegas and
you've done really well I would just
walk away from the table Yeah cash in
uh what What's the house debt
um I still owe
[Music]
and I just started doubling down yeah
what do you make
I make about a hundred and twenty
okay so you're gonna be four you're
gonna be 65 66 that's paid for is that
your plan
that's my plan every penny maybe more if
I can get more shifts okay good for you
here you got a lot of energy a lot
awesome proud of you yeah okay and
here's the good news not counting the 15
that you're continuing to add to the 350
but the 350 in that same period of time
will become 700. oh I like to hear in
that and then seven more years when
you're
73 72 that 700 will be 1.4
oh that's beautiful that's music to my
ears yeah and so and then the house is
worth what
it's it's the house is worth about 550.
okay all right yeah so in about two
years from right now you're gonna be
you're gonna have your first million net
worth
oh yeah that's where you are and and
Lori I'll tell you this Dave Dave
mentioned this on air one time when I
was here and it it was like a light bulb
went off when you turned 61
um if you're in good health chances are
you lived in 91 and suddenly you got 30
more years of investing and this thing
potentially doubling every seven years
that's a lot of money that's a whole lot
I've got I've got 80ish parents so I I
think I have some longevity genes there
you go there you go I like it that's a
good thing yeah and and you know again
because the average death age of a male
right now is uh 72 and 74 for female but
that includes infant mortality teenage
death those kinds of things and so again
when you make it within reasonably good
health into your 60s you got a high
probability statistically of making it
into your late 80s or 90s and so uh we
typically bring that up when we're
addressing oh well you're Now 60 so you
to move all your money into conservative
Investments and no inflation will kick
your butt you got 30 more years to buy
bread and gas as it goes up and so yeah
that's a but you're not we're not going
to worry about that with you Lori you're
in good shape you're doing really smart
things right yeah she's got a plan man
she dialed in
and I love the uh I don't know I I like
all the
psychological data says when people just
quit working they just stop everything
falls off and I like to hear somebody
who's 61 is like no man I'm getting
after I'm doubling my shifts I'm going
for it man I just love that I love it
it's fabulous Jace is in Las Vegas hi
Jace how are you
hey Dave how are you doing better than I
deserve how can I help
so my wife and I recently got on the
budget and we have about four or five
hundred dollars left after all of our
expenses are
taken care of and everything
um we're kind of wondering what to do
with that money
um we have
three hundred and seventy thousand
dollars of pet what kind of dad
um it's all student loans 100 of it
who's the lawyer
so I'm a doctor I am in residency I have
two more years left from the middle of
residency right now
and so what are you thinking what's your
household income
so I it's about fifty thousand dollars
after taxes let's take home my wife
stays at home with our kids oh okay all
right so these are the call these are
college Years I mean you're in college
that's what your master
yeah so it's medical school and
undergrad is about 20 000. yeah I
understand but I'm just saying uh you
know when you're in school we don't
expect people to make big strides in
their wealth building when they get out
of school
yeah your Temptation you have to avoid
then is getting what we call docitis
it's a disease that medical school
spreads
yeah no I've heard of that disease and I
studied it yeah yeah docitis is where
you go buy a new BMW to prove that
you're a new MD instead of paying off
your freaking student loans
um and so yeah you you keep driving a
hoop D and you live in a like a broke
doctor because that's what you are going
to be very soon hopefully uh a doctor
because you're currently broke we hope
we can add doctor to it and then we go
make a couple hundred a year and we
clean this up and because we don't
upscale our lifestyle
we keep our lifestyle where it is now
and then when you do graduate get your
md and move into the bigger income
that's when you'll be able to actually
make progress but you I really don't
expect you to do much but tread water
right now
yeah so we were just thinking of putting
that just kind of in a bigger emergency
type of fun honestly
yeah I would because very small amount
and make sure and make sure that that
also enables you to not take out any
more student loans or any more than you
have to just get really limited you know
quit quit just taking the full boat on
everything okay stop that and uh and
then finish up your residency you know
pass your boards and let's go make some
money and pay this money back and don't
change your lifestyle yeah it's like
that movie Spaceballs only what you need
to survive right you don't need to take
out every man the number of students
who'd come in and just take out I
qualify for how much
and they just get this huge refund check
as though it just rained on them right
and so far exceeded the cost of college
and that went to video games and TVs and
couches and for your fancy Apartments
beer more beer
and beer I worked with good students
Dave yeah you did this yeah
this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
personality is my co-host today thanks
for hanging out with us America we're
glad you're here open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
in the lobby of Ramsey Solutions on the
debt free stage Kyle and Kristen are
with us hey guys how are you good how
are you guys doing better than we
deserve now where do you live
we live in what's called
hobsonville Indiana Evansville very cool
love it welcome to Nashville how much
debt have you paid 209
678 dollars
about 10 years but that included our
house so that was kind of the last step
there
during that decade started at 72 000 and
ended at 138 000. cool what do you all
do for a living we're teachers ah very
good very good what's this house worth
uh I would imagine if we were to sell
her now be about 350 000 very cool and
how much in your nest egg and your
retirement Nest Egg a little over 120
000 in retirement probably about 70 and
529. I'll see you half a million anyway
net worth way to go guys thank you thank
you I love it how old are you two 35.
yeah you'll be millionaires by the time
you're 40. excellent excellent well done
guys well done proud of you so uh tell
me what happened uh 10 years ago they
got this journey started how long you
all been married 11 years okay so one
year into marriage boom here we go one
year into marriage and I'm the math
teacher so when we got married it was
kind of like well we should save X
dollars each month and then you know
months came and went and it was like
wait a minute we're not saving that much
so what's going on here and so my mom
kind of mentioned well I hear this guy
on am talk radio you guys should give
him a listen and so we did and then we
started listening the podcast whether we
were walking the dog running early
drives to Florida for vacation or maybe
we always had the pod on and listened to
lots of shows and uh the debt free
screams kind of got us inspired in
addition to uh all the radio listening
and then we decided
to decide this
paper on purpose so that we know exactly
where our money's going yeah okay so you
laid out a budget of course and went
after it then okay what kind of debt did
you have other than the house so I had a
little bit of student loans about 8 000
of student loans uh we we were normal we
financed the car early on in our
marriage and then uh did the same with
the minivan a couple years later so uh
so two two vehicles student loans and
the rest was the house all right wow
very good good for you wow plowed right
through how's it feel pretty good the
day we did it it was very felt like we
could breathe a little bit the bear air
felt a little different you've talked
about before the grass feels different
when you walk through it it was just
freeing very freeing
and luckily for YouTube nothing has been
weird in the world of Education the last
three to four years so exactly not owing
anybody anything except for your house
had to have been comforting because if
you're like the teachers I'm talking to
across the country and looking at this
data this Mass Exodus there had to be
moments when you thought what are we
doing how long can I keep doing this and
not own anybody any money had to feel
great and knowing we were right around
the corner from paying this house off
and then we could do whatever we want
right yeah exactly when we first started
there was a big fear of Indiana teachers
that money wasn't going to be there we
didn't know if we'd get raised as this
or that we've been fortunate that hasn't
been the case in our Corporation at
least so that was kind of one of the
things it's like we got to make sure
that we are as financially free as
possible in case a situation like that
does arise okay but you got to know how
crazy that is because everybody looks at
uncertainty and they look at the
government or some media outlet and said
save me and yaltu said all right it's
going to be uncertain times for us we're
going to have to forge ahead and solve
this with ourselves and our family and
our community dude that's that's how
communities change right there we
appreciate that it's amazing and we just
did a lot of unique or weird things like
in the winter time we kept our
thermostat at 60. our parents that
sometimes don't want to come over
because it was too cold in there but
we're trying to pay less to our energy
they're well played games we would go to
Sam's Club and stock up our freezer but
then each week we go to the grocery
store is like 35 that's what we want to
spend because we're just buying lunches
pretty much for the two of us uh yeah so
we just did lots of things that that
were weird to to try and get ahead
and now you're in a great shape well
thank you yeah you really paid a price I
mean 10 years you're stuck with it yeah
that's pretty impressive it's very very
well done well done now when people find
out your house and everything is paid
for how old are you two did you say 35
35 yeah
yeah people find out your yours are so
weird I mean if people find that out
they go how did you do that what do you
tell them the secret to getting out of
debt is well that's like what we've
talked about there really is no no
secret you put it on paper on purpose
and you follow it I mean it's it's
discipline it's no we're not gonna go
out to eat and no we're not going to get
a gift at every a store we go to the
kids hear the word know a lot and it's
just being different like you said but
being disciplined and sticking to the
plan and having the resolve to realize
that at some point it's going to pay off
at the end one thing at least I'm a
visual person so each each every so
often we'd go through and hey at this
month we should have this much of the
house paid off and it was on the
computer and if we got that we put
ourselves in the black I just have some
kind of visual reinforcement of the goal
we're working towards
perfect well done very simple like you
used to say Dave uh grandmother your
advice your grandmother used to give you
except we keep our teeth in so it's very
simple that's true that's true and then
my wife is a grandmother and I'm not
allowed to say that anymore
so anyway I need to she has all her
teeth but before we do the definition I
need you to clarify a few things because
I just want to make sure America hears
this
I'm on under the impression that
teachers no matter what simply don't
make enough money to survive in America
and they just can't get ahead true or
false that's false false
I'm under the impression that you have
to be inside your home as comfortable as
you are at a spa or everything falls
apart true or false that's awesome I'm
under the impression that if you tell
your kids you know they they evaporate
and they hate you and they kick and
scream and they become disaster like
little feral animals true or false they
do kick in streams
and then that energy runs out and there
we are
Dave talks about Hope Stealers I want
people who
consume the media on a regular basis who
have bought into some narrative that
the country's over everything has fallen
apart everything is over I want to look
at you too and you two inspire me
literally my own house with my family
because y'all have said we're going to
circle the wagons here with our home
with our family with our community with
our parents we're gonna do this the
right way and y'all did it man and
everybody listening it can be done
because I'm looking at it right here I'm
looking at three kids that are still
breathing and smiling and acting like
kids they made it right they did they
made it they were fun it's Kinley our
oldest uh about I don't know a year ago
she'd walk around with our smart money
smart kids book and she'd pull Bill
aside and read it to them and she was
just learning hospitalizing me yeah it
was fun we've got commission jars for
them they've got things have to do
around the house they save and they give
very good um it's just exciting things
very cool let's bring them up and
introduce them one of their names and
ages we got Kinley here she's our oldest
she is eight she's eight we got Cameron
he's our second he's six and we got
Lucas here he's our youngest that's
three and one in the next probably five
to six weeks all right way to go guys a
beautiful family thank you thank you you
guys are heroes those kids lives are
completely changed uh because you paid a
price to win and you taught them the
ancient word no it's a good word it has
kind of escaped our vocabulary in this
country and it's good when you can
return it one family at a time yeah
we've got the live and gift box for you
to say thanks for coming it's the baby
steps Millionaire's book which that's
your next stop for sure and then Total
Money Makeover book uh and you can pass
that on to somebody who needs to do what
you're doing and a Financial Peace
University membership if you've not gone
through it you got to go through it if
you haven't if you have and you want to
give it away do that it's it's for you
to live and to give that's what it's
called that's why it's called the living
gift box way to go guys Kyle and
Christian Kinley Cameron and Lucas guys
are you all ready to do here are you
guys ready all right here we go all
right here we go 210 000 paid off house
and everything in 10 years making 72 to
138 count it down let's hear a debt free
scream three two one
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen did you hear that
sound
it was the sound of a family tree being
changed free Dave they're free pretty
cool pretty cool this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you
our scripture today Colossians 2 8 see
to it that no one takes you captive
through Hollow and deceptive philosophy
which depends on human tradition and the
elemental Spirit spiritual forces of
this world rather than on Christ
Jordan Peterson says it this way don't
be a slave to stupid rules
it's very seldom that much and to the
point he's he's I mean short he usually
has a lot more to say I I just need you
to know that the next there's going to
be a time when I might
don't be a slave of stupid rules I might
suggest that uh one of my office rules I
don't want to be a slave to a stupid
rule I guess then you can say well then
you don't have to work here that's
pretty cool oh well they're stupid rules
and then there's just rules that's fair
[Laughter]
ah all right here we go Brandi is in
Greenville South Carolina hi Brandy
welcome to the Ramsey Show
uh hey Dave thank you for taking our
call sure what's up
okay so we are in a huge Dilemma on both
financial and um emotional we build a
house brand new in 2017. right after
moving in we started noticing a lot of
issues
long story later and along five years
worth of litigation we settled outside
of court
um now that we've settled we started
doing some of the renovations and you
know we thought we were looking really
good on budget and then one thing
um after another started popping up we
started having severe mold issues we had
it in the HVAC
um we had it in the crawl space under
the floors
um you just you can imagine it's just
mold infested
at this point we don't have any more
money from the settlement to invest in
our home
the pickle here is we don't live in a
subdivision so we can't just flip around
and sell we actually have a piece of
property that my parents gifted me now
in the beginning we were told that we
could Excel if anything were to ever
come up but now family members are
getting you know emotionally involved my
husband and I have decided that you know
we really don't want to go into debt to
fix this house unless you know it's the
right thing to do we know interest rates
are doubled what we have now what is
your household income
okay my husband makes seventy two
thousand dollars at his first job and
then his side gig he makes uh 10 000
curtain grass on the side okay so 82 000
household income and you don't work for
70. I'm sorry sorry 72 total it's 60
72 total and you don't work outside the
home
I don't I'm a home school
educator okay and how many kids have you
got
worse okay all right cool
all right and
um so what bids have you gotten on the
mold eradication
I know that we need around eighty
thousand dollars to finish this project
left
not in mold eradication
no motor mediation we have a multi
coming out on August the 10th he's
supposed to be one of the top in the you
know state of South Carolina
um you don't have any money why do you
have the top guy in the whole state
coming out because the other people that
we've had in our home
um you know we've spent
um fifteen thousand in the crawl space
we're media remediating that and then we
spent
um so far just in the foreign portion of
it around 12 000.
yeah well we have more mold that we're
discovering
so that's yes I'm confused I mean
because if you have a crawl space home
and there's mold in the crawl space and
you eradicate the crawl space and you
and you clean the heat and air ducts you
should be done
well yes but it's in the walls we've you
know that's the thing we found some
things that are in the walls that need
to be addressed so that would be an
additional fee all of the other things
you know have been addressed um it's
just the new things why is it eighty
thousand dollars in that's not true best
to complete the whole entire house I
know um you know but you can't afford it
you haven't you haven't
yeah oh I know that's why we're back in
our Corner because every last penny that
we had
um you know for the remediation
um or you know the Renault it went into
the motor mediation because all your
moles should be done I mean you it
should be done but maybe just a little
bit so there's two separate issues
you're lumping it all into one issue and
turning it into a drama okay the other
Renovations I don't care when you do
those
but the mold has to be taken care of to
live there
well we don't that's the thing we don't
live there we've been living with my
parents because it was so bad okay so
the mold has to be finished but all the
the other Renovations don't have to be
done to move in
well actually they do because our house
is gutted we have no bathrooms we have
no flooring we have nothing in our home
no kitchen everything has been completed
how much did you get of a settlement
um 150 000. and you couldn't fit and you
all you did was get the house gutted for
150 Grand yes we got
the full stuff landscape stuff and I
mean yes we've put everything
Landscaping you don't do landscaping
with your house gutted and no bathrooms
like regrading the
grated our yard into the um easier to
push this thing down
that's what I was saying from the
beginning
and
we know what do you owe on it 211
if it was in Tip-Top shape everything
was done you you had eighty thousand
dollars fall from the sky
what what could you sell it for
speaking with a few Realtors and that's
what they think that the number is yeah
so you'll be lucky to get out of it
right now
yeah that's what we're just trying to
see should we sell as is do we need to
do uh you know a homework you all suck
at Renovations so I really your ability
to manage this project in this budget is
horrible you've it just has destroyed
you and so
um I really don't want you continuing
this because you're not it's gonna you
know you did when you were building it
didn't get done right and then when you
try to do a renovation with the amount
of money you had you didn't stay on
budget and you got completely out of
control on on everything and so it's
like there's no limit to spending here
um so I mean oh gosh um
yeah I don't think this ends well even
if you went and borrowed 80 grand
I don't think that's the end of it
because I don't think I think something
else is going to come up because you all
don't do this well
yeah and that's what we're afraid of you
know
yeah I mean I know well enough and I've
made a lot of financial you know
mistakes and we were really trying to so
how many acres is it
it's on one and a half acres and it's
adjacent to what your parents or
something
yes yeah okay
well I mean yeah you don't have a choice
you got to sell it it does it doesn't
make sense there's nothing here that
says I want to keep this
uh hopefully you can get more than 210
for it
um and then you're just gonna have to go
and get your rental property and then
start rebuilding your lives and if Mom
and Dad or whoever it is that's griping
at you don't like that then they can buy
it
yeah but they don't they don't really
have a vote in whether you keep it
unless they're gonna unless they give
you 80 grand if they give you an 80
grand then as a gift then they can have
a vote
yes sir but they don't get to tell you
what to do with your property that's
part of the problem when giving someone
something they now own it
you when Dave just said you got to sell
it
yes sir did they give you peace
um yes and no I mean that was our
forever home so
seems like the cosmos is trying to tell
you no it's not no it's not no it's not
yes that's what and that's where I just
kind of stopped and ask my husband you
know we've been out of the house we
can't
seems that we thought things were going
to be completely different and it's not
it's been the opposite from the
beginning so
yeah I'm not opposed I'm not going to
sit here and dig my heels in to keep
something just because of family land
I'm not either I'm not either I'm sorry
it's family land but if the family wants
to buy a thing about it or if they want
to give you a hundred thousand dollars
cash gift and you want to try to finish
it so that that's fine if somebody's
rich and wants to put their money where
their mouth is otherwise they don't get
a vote
so I'm sorry you've been through all
this yeah if I were in your shoes I'd be
done with it I want a fresh start I'll
be done with it that puts the sour in
the Ramsey showing the books we'll be
back with you before you know it in the
meantime remember there's ultimately
only one way to financial peace and
that's to walk daily with the Prince of
Peace Christ Jesus
Dave here you can find all of our shows
with the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
thank you
[Music]